bien estamos en el problema número 20 es
el último de esta sección así que aquí
tengo el problema número 20 y voy a
cambiar a esta herramienta y tengo un
paralelogramo como te decía en el vídeo
pasado así que vamos a dibujarlo tengo
un paralelogramo más o menos así tengo
algo más o menos así después algo más o
menos así ok después algo más o menos
así algo más o menos así ok y después
esto sube algo más o menos así y tengo
esta diagonal menor está dieron el menor
y me dicen que todos los lados de este
para el dow gramo y también la diagonal
son congruentes eso quiere decir que a
este lado es congruente a este lado
tienen la misma longitud que es lo mismo
que este lado que es lo mismo que este
lado que es lo mismo que este lado por
ciento nos dan dos vértices este es el
vértice am ok este es el vértice ven ok
este es el vértice sen ok y este es el
vértice de y me dicen que la diagonal
el pd es igual a 1 por lo tanto si esta
diagonal vale 1 antes de ponerlo con
otro color este digo no vale 1 este lado
también vale 1 este también vale 1 éste
también vale 1 y esto también vale 1 y
no sólo eso como tenemos triángulos
fíjate ese triángulo de aquí como
tenemos triángulos equiláteros sabemos
que este ángulo mide 60 grados ok este
ángulo de aquí también mide 60 grados ok
este también mide 60 grados ok este
también mide 60 grados ok este también
mide 60 grados ok y este también mide 60
grados ok y todo esto para que porque lo
que me preguntan es cuál es la razón de
la diagonal mayor a comparación de la
diagonal menor y vamos a pintar aquí la
diagonal mayor y me gusta este color
para la diagonal mayor esté aquí vamos a
ponerlo con color blanco esta diagonal
mayor es justo lo que me preguntan cuál
es su longitud o visto desde otra manera
pues la razón de la diagonal mayor a
comparación de la diagonal menor ahora
lo que quiero que veas es lo siguiente y
esto es muy importante esta diagonal y
me dice acá a este ángulo es decir que
este ángulo se va a partir justo a la
mitad déjame cambiar la herramienta este
ángulo va a partirse justo a la mitad y
cuando yo no cruzo con esta diagonal y
de igual manera este ángulo como sé que
esto parte de la mitad a este ángulo ok
30 grados 30 grados y este ángulo bueno
porque tenemos lados congruentes si
tenemos lados congruentes esta diagonal
debe de pasar justo por el punto medio
de este lado deben debe pasar justo por
el punto medio porque todos los lados
miden lo mismo como éste para él
logramos es completamente simétrico
entonces cuando yo cruce con la diagonal
mayor voy a obtener que va a visitar a
este ángulo o va a pasar por el punto
medio y no sólo eso si eso pasa entonces
tú no puedes decir cuánto mide este
ángulo este ángulo va a ser un ángulo
recto si aquí tengo 30 grados 60 grados
entonces aquí me faltan 90 grados para
llegar al 180 grados es un ángulo recto
y es que esto está padrísimo porque si
aquí tengo un ángulo recto y entonces
éste mide 30 grados y este mide 60
grados ya puedo obtener la medida de la
diagonal mayor y ojo se me hace muy
importante mencionar que no todas las
diagonales de un par del dow gramo se
cruzan en un ángulo recto este es un
caso muy especial me tocó un para el dow
gramo donde todos sus lados son
congruentes y por eso se intersectan las
dos diagonales en un ángulo recto pero
no siempre es así lo importante aquí es
fijarse que la diagonal mayor biseca a
este ángulo o pasa por el punto medio
como lo quieras ver porque porque ahora
quiero que te fijes en el siguiente
triángulo fíjate en este siguiente
triángulo vamos a darnos cuenta y vamos
a observar este este y este triángulo ok
este triángulo lo voy a poner aquí aquí
tengo este triángulo tengo algo así algo
así y algo así hice varias cosas de este
triángulo lo primero que sé es que este
ángulo mide 60 grados este ángulo mide
60 grados este dakar mide 30 grados este
de acá mide 30 grados ok am éste mide 90
grados ok esta distancia en mide 1 esta
distancia en mide 1 y además este lado
éste cateto es la mitad de mi diagonal
mayor es la mitad de media con el mayor
y no sólo eso también sé cuánto mide
esta parte de aquí si pasa justo por el
punto medio esta parte de aquí debe de
medir un medio debe de medir 1 y debe de
medir un medio porque pasa justo por la
mitad o porque me seca a este ángulo y
entonces ya podemos calcular cuánto vale
este cateto de aquí este cateto de aquí
a vamos a llamarle a este cateto ar lo
podemos sacar como la raíz cuadrada de
uno menos uno al cuadrado menos un medio
elevado al cuadrado esto utilizando un
teorema de pitágoras de aquí acá
solamente utilice un teorema de
pitágoras que por cierto esto es lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada de uno menos
un cuarto que es lo mismo que la raíz
cuadrada de tres cuartos que es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de tres entre dos
del lujo ya sé que la mitad de mi
diagonal mayor es decir que este lado es
lo mismo que la raíz de tres entre dos
pero toda toda mi diagonal mayor sería
dos veces esto o sumar este más este y
cuanto sería eso la diagonal hace la
diagonal hace la puedo obtener como raíz
de tres entre dos más la raíz de 3
es decir este pedazo de aquí este de
aquí que me de raíz de tres sobre dos
más este de aquí estoy aquí que mide
exactamente lo mismo raíz de tres sobre
dos porque tenemos por los triángulos
equiláteros y esto es decir hace es lo
mismo que raíz de tres raíz de tres
entre dos más raíz de tres entre dos
pues el raíz de tres y ya tengo el valor
de la diagonal mayor eso está del lujo
porque si ya tengo el valor de la
diagonal mayor entonces ya puedo
concluir cuál es la relación de la
diagonal mayor a comparación de la
diagonal menor si la diagonal menor mide
1 y la diagonal mayor mide 3 raíz de 3
perdón entonces la razón es igual a la
raíz de 3 a 1 raíz de 3 a 1 es la razón
de este problema que es justo lo que me
pedían perfecto y aún si está asisten
mis respuestas es el inciso b lo único
que teníamos que calcular en este
problema era la diagonal mayor y esa lo
obtuvimos fijándonos en puros triángulos
equiláteros de lujo problema número 20
en el siguiente vídeo empezaré unas
nuevas
hasta la próxima